I've got a picture of you at the Oscars
the night of the Oscars and so this
diamond almost look I look just like
that right now
that's so weird it's uncanny but that is
the diamond that diamond is in the
middle of that Breakfast at Tiffany's
yeah so that diamond was in a necklace
that Audrey were for pressed for
breakfast at tiffany's and then the
diamond was put into a different setting
and it's is this priceless diamond that
Tiffany's had and they they offered it
to me to wear at the Oscars and I was
you know the street kidded me from New
York hell yeah I'm gonna work that big
thing but does it not gonna wreck your
night because presumably you've got
security guards under each arm pit and
there's like there's people crawling all
over here
I already thought I had too much
security before I put that diamond on
and then I put that diamond on and I was
like am I the president like I didn't
really know what was going on and it was
really funny because I really didn't
know what was gonna happen that night I
was just excited to be there you know
that's mostly generally how I feel that
these events is like oh I'm just happy
to be here right and so then I won an
Oscar and I was so excited and I'm
having champagne and I'm drinking and my
sister was my date so you know like
we're really barreling through the
champagne backstage with the Oscar and I
just leave and I leave with the diamond
on and I didn't tell anyone like I just
left and Tiffany started freaking out
they're like she's gods she she left
with the diamond and actually I went to
go hang out with Madonna at her managers
house and I got to the house and I was I
was just chilling with Madonna my like
all these security guards were like just
side-eyeing me from you know every
corner of the room and every time I
hugged someone they they would like like
get a little closer to make sure it was
still on and then and then I left and I
really wanted to go to Taco Bell so we
were trying to go to Taco Bell and then
all of a sudden the car got pulled over
by Tiffany's security and it was very
politely moved removed from
neck
[Music]
you